foreign
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
[Music]
how y'all doing all y'all that don't
know who I am my name is Willie Gary
Willie Gary Willie William Gary never
heard of him what's so special about
this guy anyway
[Music]
S I know you got myself into a lot of
trouble I've been your lawyer 30 years
we can find a way out of it you've never
sued anybody before in your whole life
Stella tried to bully me out of business
and I don't think I should be expected
to stand for it Prof hasn't lost the
case in over 12 years you suggesting I
hire this guy's one of my lawyers y'all
come on in pleasure to meet you Mr Gary
let me introduce you to my call Red how
do you feel about working with black
folk I suppose I am a little Prejudice
did you meet my team
Douglas chairman he's suing us he's
suing us we are a half a billion dollar
cooperation so how much money y'all
trying to get eight million that ain't
enough money 100 million dollars
who is this clown he's hired as a lawyer
your fighter man what made you want to
do because he tried to mess with the one
thing that means the most to me in life
being able to leave something behind for
my grandchildren
my name is Maine Downs graduated top of
her class from Harvard Law School they
had a nickname for her around the office
the python I wouldn't get too used to me
being kind to you Mr Gary once we begin
that trial
I want to destroy you
can't you see that we're golden we only
have a snowball's chance in hell of
winning this case just just trust me
okay I I may have found something what
does it feel like to be some small time
nobody on the verge of bankruptcy
have been trying to turn this into your
own one raining circus I got my damn
life on the line I know that Jerry
did it ever bother you hypocrisy the
hypocrisy
split the pole
come on
we're golden